hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're in round
3 of the 2015 sync failed cup our
competitor today whites gonna be played
by Wesley so American third American in
the tournament we've already covered two
Americans already round one we looked at
Nakamura and then round two we looked at
Fabien on Caruana Wesley so lost his
first round tied in the second round so
looking to bounce back with the white
pieces in round three his competitor is
gonna be Alexander gillies shook on the
black pieces from Russia also very
strong player lost in round one and won
in round two so victory here would be
huge for him catapulting him to the top
are near the top at least of the
standing so we'll go ahead and get
started
Wesley so decides to start with pawn to
c4 the English opening pawn to c5 Knight
f3 knight c6 Knight c3 and then Knight
to f6 so going into the symmetrical
English both sides pretty much copying
each other's moves at the beginning of
the game
I'll see pawn to g3 getting ready to
fianchetto the bishop here to g2 pawn
here to g7 Bishop here to G to
fianchetto and then pawn to d6 just
solidifying the pawn chain a little bit
opening up the door for this lightsworn
Bishop to get involved in this the
action here on d7 and then castle on the
Kings side and then Bishop here to g7
fianchetto pawn up here to d4 Wesley
really has no reason to play passive
kind of mirror with this pawn here to d3
he should be the aggressor he has the
white pieces so there's no reason to
kind of sit back so pawn to d4 kind of
pushes the action I wants to make sure
he is kind of controlling the center of
the board early on so after the capture
and recapture we see bishop here to d7
now although black is opening up the
door to castle on the Queen side pretty
much never going to see this with your C
file open here you're going to want to
bring your rook over here to see aids
control this long semi open file but
your King would just be too exposed to
castle on the Queen side so both sides
pretty much know that GUI shook is
eventually going to cash flow here on
the kingside pawn appear to be three
Wesley had a few options here Knight
here to b3 comes to mind can always play
Knight takes on
c6 Bishop capture here and that appeared
to d5 a little outpost move rook over
here to see AIDS this seems like a
pretty logical step in this opening but
decides instead to go for the pawn to b3
nothing wrong with this opening up the
door if the dark square bishop does want
to come maybe fee and keto here - B -
that's fine Knight takes here and the
Queen's going to recapture Bishop here
to c6 just more of a central control
square for this Bishop also making sure
that white does not control this long
light square diagonal right here with
his bishop here on D - bishop here - b2
as we talked about and then castle on
the Kings side and then Knight up here
to d5 trying to just block off the
center of the board and open up the door
for his dark squared bishop to kind of
reign supreme
he now has both his Queen and his bishop
kind of locked and loaded on this long
dark square diagonal if he should have
decides to go ahead and take here and
then the pawn recaptures here doesn't
want to give up could have recapture
with his Bishop but decides wants to go
ahead and stick with the double bishop
pair I think this does favour White's
this is a fairly open game and it's
gonna be fairly easy to keep it open and
double bishop pair much better in an
open game than a knight and a bishop now
the Queen's gonna come over here to a5
and as we can look at the board state
this C file is no longer just a
semi-open file it's completely open here
so both sides need to be thinking about
getting their roofs over here and
controlling this long C file right here
a bishop up here to c3 just attacking
the Queen and then Queen up here - a6
White has a few options but decides to
go in and come back here with Queen to
d2 a rook over here to see H trying to
control that long file and they look
over here to see one it and White has a
few options both makes sense rook here
to see one since he does have his queen
protecting this pawn over here on a 2
from this Queen right here it's okay to
bring either the rook over here to see
one or this rook over here to see one
Wesley so decides to go and bring as
we're going here to see one nothing
wrong with that but I think they're
about the same can play a little bit
different but for the most part they're
gonna be doing the same thing Queen here
to b5 rook over here to b1
pun over here to a 5 and then pond up
here to e4
so whites really trying to control these
light squares in the center of the board
now Bishop has a few options he could
keep this night here and continue to put
pressure on this pawn I think that's not
a bad idea at all or he has the other
option when she chose to do and that
spring his Knight up here to d7 he has a
few outpost he can come to c5 he can
come to e5 try to control the center of
the board like that but then all of a
sudden this Bishop right here on g2 no
longer has to worry about protecting
this pawn white no longer has to worry
about maybe bringing a rook over here to
e1 to protect this pawn right here so
although it's gonna have a better attack
potentially on c5 or a 5 this pawn just
doesn't have to worry as much as it did
before which comes into play later in
the game so Bishop taking here on g7 and
then the recapture here and then Queen
up here to d4 check forcing the King to
move so came back here to g8 Bishop down
here to f1 threatening this Queen as we
looked at before this Bishop no longer
has to worry about this pawn here on e4
so decides to go ahead and get
aggressive get into the action so Mitch
Peter to f1 forcing the Queen back
there's a little in-between move first
the rook ticking here on c1 Bishop
cannot take first here on b5 just
because his king would fall and you
can't do that it's a legal move so after
rook takes here on a c1 now the Queen's
gonna come down here to be for Wesley
now plays rook here to c4 and he
recognizes that he could just take here
on b4 with his Queen exchange off
material more than likely it's going to
be a draw but he's kind of looking
around the room and says I got the best
players in the world I haven't won a
game yet I'm lost and I tied another tie
I'm gonna have one point after three
rounds that's not good enough so he
recognizes who wants to make anything
happen he needs to play a little bit
more aggressive so that's exactly what
he does and I agree with it he plays
rook up here to c4 now the Queen down
here to e1 just kind of a not great
attack
but trying to be as aggressive as
possible doesn't have the rest of his
homies over here to kind of help him out
but it does kind of stop this Bishop
here on f1 from doing too much now Rick
up here to c7 if you're ever wondering
where your rook should belong Bloom
belongs on open files that's key number
one but beyond that it belongs on your
opponent's 7th ranks so many bad things
can happen to your opponent they usually
have a lot of pawns on the 7th rank or
if you're black over here on the second
rank this particular case also has a
knight here now
luckily for de guiche Ganesha he does
have a knight here to e5 which threatens
a just dirty fork here on f3 which would
lose the Queen
so does have kind of that in-between
move that white just can't completely
dominate the 7th rank but still this
rook here on c7 is very dangerous and
black his rook here on a a it's not
doing anything and it can't really do
anything doesn't have any support
decided you know Bishop early on decided
to go ahead and exchange a rook here on
c1 so kind of looking back he may
actually want both of his rooks back
here
but for now Wesley decides he needs to
go ahead and protect himself so it
doesn't lose this Queen makes sense so
King up here to g2 now Queen back here
to be for protecting this pawn here on
b7 now there's a few options if we kind
of look at it's interesting how much
things can change instead of Queen here
- before we could have seen Queen to be
1 another option that he had he was kind
of looking at the board so you never
really know exactly what they were gonna
play but from here we could have seen
pawn here to a3 we should have seen the
Queen capture here now Bishop up here to
e - this is important just because it
has a blocker once this pawn moves up
here to f4 it kind of stops at any any
threat of a check here on the second
rank right here
but now pawn down here to b5 this is
also an important move because after
pawn here to f4 now this Knight has an
outpost here on a c4 but then after the
outpost we see the rook come over here
to e7 if the Queen takes doesn't have to
take but if the Queen takes there on a3
then after the Bishop takes and the pawn
takes we see the Queen recapture and
then all of a sudden we see this pass
pawn over here on a
five and then over on the kingside white
just has a ton more material so very
very different game Ganesha easily could
have had a passed pawn not necessarily
say that it's easy for him to push this
because it's not at all especially with
one Queen in front and a rook behind
it's a little more dangerous to try to
protect this against his opponent that's
kind of controlling the center of the
board and putting a lot of pressure on
the Kings side as well but those are
some of the options that they did have
if we kind of go back you know some bad
stuff could have happened you know from
here instead of that Bishop here to e2
if we would have seen rook over here to
e7 well that's actually a pretty big
mistake the Queen can now come over here
to f3 check and then after the King
moves then queen up here to f6
threatening this rook and if the rook
moves then that's gonna be bad because
now the Knights just gonna come here to
f3 fork this Queen it's very very bad so
all-in-all a lot of stuff could have
changed there's all these small little
subtlety moves you see Queen back here
to b4 okay he's gonna protect this pawn
on b7 but a lot of could change if he
didn't play that and he definitely did
not have to play that but after Queen
here - before now we see the exchange on
board and this I think is better for
Wesley so than the position we looked at
earlier he now has a more aggressive
piece here on c7 so recognize it okay my
opponent now has double pawns I have a
very aggressive piece here on c7 I have
the better minor piece so he decided
this is a much better time to go ahead
and exchange those Queens off the board
white now played a rook here to see - he
had the option of playing rook taking
here on e7 allowing his opponent to come
down here to a2 he just didn't want to
have to worry about his opponent
actually having his own rook on his
second rank so decided to go and play a
rook down here to see - protecting this
pawn but still he has control of the C
file which is very very important King
over here to g7 pawn up here to f4 and
now Knight here to a d7 King up here too
f 3 and then pawn down here to f5 and
this is a move where it seems okay but I
really think that the knight in this
position has to come to c5 at any time
this route can kind of blow through come
back here to the seventh rank if you
wanted to and just make life really
really miserable for black this night
here on c5 blocks that it's a really
nice outpost it's very difficult for
white to deal with the bishop is the
LightSquared bishop so I can't touch it
none of these pawns are really gonna be
able to deal with it maybe there's an
exchange on the board on b4 but beyond
that this Knight controls a lot of the
board and I really like the position of
it even if there's an exchange on the
ponds that can always recapture here on
d6 so I like this move a lot more but
instead they decide to go and play pawn
to f5 we see an exchange off the board
this is kind of opening up the board a
little bit which also favors I think the
side with the bishop which is white in
this particular case now Rick appear to
c7 as we set this and I don't think this
is very good for black now Knight to c5
blocking off not as much and then work
over here to e7 capturing material King
here to f6 now the rook swings back here
to e2 holding down this material on a to
pawn over here to h5 King here it's III
just centralizing we're now in the in
game so you want to centralize your King
it's a very valuable piece to actually
play into it doesn't have to worry about
any crazy attacks that can really
checkmate his King so actually using it
in the game as a powerful piece is
important upon up here to d4 threatening
the the Knights we do see an exchange of
material here on g3 now rook up here to
III just solidifying the position a
little bit controlling this long file in
the center of the board the e-file and
also protecting this pawn here on g3
rook over here to a8 King here to c4
would you see an exchange here on a 4
and B 4 but white kind of has a plan
he's gonna march up the board it's gonna
take this pawn he's then gonna have a
passed pawn he's gonna march his own pot
up get a king destroy his opponent he's
gonna
win the game that's his plan right now
it's gonna be very difficult for black
to actually stop that plan we're just
gonna swing over here to F to a bishop
here to c4 just protecting both those
pawns right now there's not much that
this Knight can really do as far as
attacking this King all the light
squares that he would actually go to are
all kind of taken maybe Knight up here
to d7 but that doesn't even really do
too much so Knight here to e4 King over
here to b5 kind of as we talked about
and from here black decided to go ahead
and resign what's interesting is this
was after move 40 this was just one move
after that and so both sides had an
additional hour to play while I do think
White has a better in game by far it's
it's very maybe minor if you kind of
look at the board right now I think
white goes on to win this many many
times maybe 95% of the time but I still
would have liked to see Alexander
Ganesha pactually try you know it's so
close that there could easily be we've
already seen mistakes some from some of
the top players in the world so I don't
like resigning in this position I do
think he was just kind of frustrated
with some of his moves and decided to go
ahead and pack it up and leave but hey
all in all that is chess Wesley so gets
the victory here after the resignation
from black so congratulations to him
always good to see my opinion Americans
especially in a tournament in st. Louis
Missouri
getting some wins especially after
Fabiano had such a hard time yesterday
starting out oh into in the tournament
so congratulations to Wesley hopefully
you guys enjoyed this tournaments pretty
awesome so far if you're not covering
some of the other matches make sure
you're doing that and I'll see you guys
in the next video thanks for watching